Тимошенко, Порошенко, Зеленський…
За кого ж голосувати…
Це питання, за тиждень до виборів, бентежить багатьох українців…
Скажіть, знаєте, за кого будете голосувати на виборах?
Поки ще не визначилась.
Ще не вирішила, дякую!
Поки ще ні
Ще ні, ще думаю, думаю.
Ми ж вирішили дізнатись, як переконують голосувати за кандидатів - в агітаційних наметах.
Зізнаюсь, знайти їх в Києві цьогоріч не так просто…
Міцно тримаються не лише намети з обличчям кандидатки Юлії Тимошенко,
але й, згідно з соцопитуваннями, її рейтинги.
Її штаб найактивніше розставляє намети по Києву.
Тут можна і газету взяти, і передвиборчу програму погортати.
Втім, поговорити з агітаторами - зась.
Ми не маємо права… ми роздаємо інформаційну літературу. Все!
Можливо, в іншому наметі кандидатки пощастить більше?
Типу ви немаєте права нас знімати, типу.. ось так..
А тут?
Ви як жінка повинні розуміти, що країною має керувати жінка!
А ви як чоловік?
Я, як чоловік?
Мені здається, що чоловік похабно відноситься до жінки, до нашої, до України.
20-річний агітатор каже - "Вечірні Вісті" від Юлії Тимошенко розбирають поволі,
чого не скажеш про цінну канцелярію.
Ручки-блокнотики? Вони є, але їх зранку всі розбирають..
Рейтинги чинного президента падають…
Але й політична кампанія Порошенка така сумна,
що навіть у його ж агітаційних наметах агітують за інших..
Ви за президента?
Як казала Тимошенко, я за народ.
Про останні журналістські розслідування щодо розкрадання в оборонному секторі тут чули.
Але не вірять. Кажуть, Порошенко - великий меценат.
Якщо він стільки грошей дав на армію, своїх, здобутків, як він може сам в себе красти!
А ось відомий шапкрад з Давосу Ігор Шевченко про друзів попіклувався.
А про виборців забув..
Шапки даєте?
Були раніше, але зараз вроді немає, вже не роздаємо.
І хоч Ігор Шевченко за всіма рейтингами непрохідний, та в наметах - без надії сподіваються…
Які шанси?
Я думаю, що досить такі непогані...
У Володимира Зеленського з рейтингами все краще.
Змінити це вирішив його конкурент Сергій Каплін.
Свіжий випуск присвятив коміку та тому, чому за нього краще не голосувати.
Основна частина знаходиться на задній сторінці газети, можете почитати.
Не зрозуміло лише, як сталось, що молодь, яка за Зеленського роздає газети, проти нього.
Мабуть, такий жарт.
Вся молодь голосує за Зеленського. Я теж думаю, варто за нього. А за кого ж ще?
Не за газетою, агіткою, а за конкретною домогою приходять до намету кандидата
від Опозиційного Блоку - Олександра Вілкула.
За матеріальною, мабуть... Дожили до такого, що всі хочуть якоїсь допомоги...
Це не лише пенсіонери, але й студенти. Втім є у них одна спільна риса…
В основному віряни, віруючі Московського патріархату.
Він прихожанин Лаври, з Новінським вони коріфани і туди ходять…
А ось Анатолій Гриценко навіть у агітаційній кампанії проявив себе як військовий.
Намет сховали далеко від центру, утім, кажуть, в стратегічному місці: біля студентських гуртожитків.
Штаб серйозно підійшов до зйомок і вже за нас вирішив, як краще зняти.
Ми даємо (газету) , спілкуємось, а ви знімаєте. І Андрюха дає інтерв’ю.
Тож далі слово Андрію… який, до речі, працює в штабі рік - за ідею, а не за гроші.
Вірить в кандидата і у його досвід…
В нього чудове резюме, у нього немає бізнесу і бізнес-інтересів,
судячи з його послужного списку, у нього дуже добрі аналітичні здібності.
Я думаю, що такому кандидату варто довірити нашу країну на 5 років.
Загалом, настрої в агітаційних наметах дружні.
На одній площі мирно співіснують прихильники різних політичних сил.
Обговоюють, зокрема, і можливі варіанти другого туру виборів.
Хто пройде - стане несподіванкою для усіх.